atom modellerini anlattık sonra Orbital
dedik yörünge dedik Peki Orbital neydi
Orbital çeşitleri nasıldı Bu ders
bunlardan bahsedeceğim mes kemi kimya
kanalına Hoş geldin dostum konunun pdf'i
Açıklama kısmında var zeda comom a
girerek oradan ne yapabilirsin
indirebilirsin dostum o zaman vakit
kaybetmiyoruz hazırsan başlayalım atom
modelleri ve elektron dizilimi
dediğimizde şöyle bir şey vardı Bor atom
modelinde bahsettik yörünge kavramı
vardı ama daha sonradan gelen modern
atom modelinde yani kuantum atom
modelinde Orbital kavramından
bahsediyorlardı
Vital dediğimiz şey nasıl ortaya çıktı
şöyle söyleyeyim Öncelikle Schrödinger
kuantum sayılarından bahsetti bu kuantum
sayılarını şöyle ifade etti Baş kuantum
sayısı açısal Momentum kuantum sayısı
manyetik kuantum sayısı ve Spin kuantum
sayısı şeklinde ifade etti burada açısal
Momentum kuantum sayısı ile Baş kuantum
sayısını söyleyeceğim dostum çünkü
bunlar neyi ifade ediyor Onu açıklamam
gerekiyor Mesela Baş kuantum sayısı
enerji seviyesini yani hangi katmanda
olduğunu belirtiyor katman yok da işte
hangi elektron bulutunda olduğunu
belirtiyor açısal Momentum kuantum
sayısı ise orbitalin türünü belirtiyor
Normalde müfredat içerisinde çok detaylı
bir şekilde görmeyeceksin ama
orbitallerin enerjilerini kıyaslarken
çok faydası oluyor o yüzden kısaca
bahsedeceğim dostum İşte bu atomun
enerji seviyelerinin Bir de alt enerji
seviyeleri vardı işte açısal Momentum
kuantum sayısı dediğimiz şey buydu Bu da
orbitallerin türünü ifade ediyor dör
tane Orbital imiz var şöyle yakından
göstereyim s orbitali p orbitali d
orbitali ve F orbitalinden bahsediyoruz
Bu dört tane orbitalin şöyle ifade
ediyoruz bak katman sayıları bu mesela
birinci katman ikinci katman 3üncü
katman veya işte enerji seviyesi Bunlar
da bak her bölüm is böyle farklı
bölümler var ya bunlar da işte o
katmandaki neyler orbitaller şeklinde
düşünebilirsin dostum ve elektron
çekirdeğe ne kadar yakınsa enerjisi o
kadar düşük ne kadar dışarıdayız yani
enerji seviyesi ne kadar büyükse haliyle
oradaki orbitalin ve elektronun da
enerjisi o kadar büyük olacak Dostum
şimdi sana şöyle bir pratik not
vereceğim şöyle bir ifade kullanmak
istiyorum boş bir sayfa açayım şimdi
Normalde n dediğimiz şey işte Baş
kuantum sayısı 1 2 3 4 5 6 ve 7 7 katman
var ya o mantıkla düşünebilirsin Baş
kuantum sayısı bu Bir de açısal Momentum
kuantum sayısı dediğimiz bir şey var l
harfiyle gösteriliyor Biz 0 1 2 ve 3'ü
bileceğiz 0 olduğunda s orbitalin 1
olduğunda p orbitalin 2 olduğunda D
orbitalin ve 3 olduğunda F orbitalin
ifade ediyor dediğim Bak bu Normalde
müfredat içerisinde detaylı bir şekilde
gösterilmiyor sadece Enerjileri bulurken
kullanacağım dolayı bunu veriyorum sana
ve şöyle bir şey var mesela birinci
katmanda sadece s orbitali var diyoruz
ikinci katmanda s ve p orbitali var ya
Bunu nasıl söyleyebiliyoruz onu
açıklamak için bunu yapıyorum Dostum
şimdi şöyle bir şey vardır bir
katmandaki en büyük Orbital türü Aslında
en büyük L değeri diye ifade etmek
istiyorum n - 1 ile bulunur şimdi o
zaman n = 1 ise burada L en fazla 0
Olabilir bak En fazla 0 olabilir 0
olduğunda s Orbital Demek ki 1ci
katmanda sadece 1 S orbitali bulunabilir
2ci katmana geldiğimizde ise n = 2 ya L
en fazla n - 1'den 2 - 1'den 1 olabilir
1 varsa 0 da vardır daha küçük sayılar
olabilir dostum o zaman 2ci katmanda 2s
orbitali ve 2p orbitali olacaktır 3
katmana bakarsak n = 3 L en fazla 2
olacaktır Demek ki 1 ve 0 da
bulunabilecek 3 katmanda 3S 3p 3D
orbitalleri bulunabilir ve 4 katmana
bakarsak şöyle yazalım ha n = 4 şeklinde
belirtelim Bu da L en fazla 3 demektir
Demek ki 2 1 ve 0 da bulunabilir e 0
olduğunda s orbitali yani 4 S orbitali
vardır 4p orbitali 4D orbitali ve 4F
orbitali varmış o zaman s orbitalleri
dediğimizde s orbitali nereden başlıyor
1 2 3 diye gidiyor p orbitali
dediğimizde 2 katmandan başlıyor 2 3 4
diye gidiyor D orbitali 3 katmandan
başlıyor 3 4 5 diye gidiyor ve F
orbitali 4 katmandan başlıyor 5 6 7 diye
gidiyor Dostum şimdi artık S
orbitalinden bahsedebilirim şöyle bir
şey vardır s orbitali her katmanda
bulunur ve şekli böyle daireseldir yani
açısal koordinatlara bağlı değildir yani
x düzlemi y düzlemi Z düzlemi böyle bir
düzlemde yoktur dostum toparlak böyle
top şek şeklinde düşünebilirsin S
orbitali böyle nedir küre şeklindedir ve
katman sayısı arttıkça bu kürre de
büyümektedir o zaman bunların
enerjilerini kıyasla Dersem ne olacaktır
1 s'nin en küçük sonra 2s en büyük
bunların arasında 3S olacaktır Tabii 7s
en büyük onu söyleyebiliriz s
orbitalleri içerisinde ve çok önemli bir
bilgi vardır en fazla iki elektron
alabilir Çünkü s orbitali bir tanedir
bak çok önemli bir şey s orbitali bir
tanedir Bundan dolayı da ne yapacaktır
en fazla ik elektron alabilecektir yani
s'nin üzer yerine en fazla kaç
yazabiliyoruz 2 yazabiliyoruz ya da s
üzeri 1 de yazabilirsin 1 ya da 2
alabilmektedir şimdi şöyle bir şey düşün
işte neden sebebi şu S orbitalinin bir
tane olmasından kaynaklanıyor böyle
gösterebilirsin veya böyle
gösterebilirsin bunları Mesela şöyle bir
yukarı bir aşağı Böyle yazılır onların
hepsini açıklayacağım veya işte şöyle
yazılabilir veya şöyle yazılabilir bu
şekilde gösterilecek s orbitali bir
tanedir onu da söylemiş olalım p
orbitaline geldiğimizde ise p orbitali
açısal koordinatlar bağlıdır yani x y z
düzlemler doğru gidecektir düzlemde
böyle iki ayrı labut şeklinde
gözükmektedir He Burada da yazıyor işte
çekirdeğin iki tarafında zıt yönelmiş
iki loptan oluşmaktadır Böyle gördüğün
gibi işte sonsuzluk işaretine benziyor
bu x düzlemi üzerinde olursa px orbitali
y düzlemi üzerinde olursa işte py
orbitali Z düzleminde olursa da pz
orbitali ifadesini kullanıyoruz o zaman
p orbitali kaç taney demiş şöyle
bakarsak p orbitali 3 taney demiş dostum
böyle de yazabilirsin şu şekilde de
gösterebilirsin dostum ve şu vardır bir
Orbital türünün alt orbitalleri yani p
orbitali dediğimizde 3 tane var ya
buradaki px p y pz aynı enerjiye
sahiptir tamam mı Bir orbitalin
içerisindekiler hepsi aynı enerjiye
sahiptir tekrar söylüyorum Bir Orbital
türünün içerisindeki orbitaller aynı
enerjiye sahiptir o zaman bir Orbital 2
elektron alabildiğine göre p en fazla
kaç alabilir 6 elektron alabilir yani
P'nin üzerine en fazla kaç
yazabiliyormuyuz
D orbitaline geldiğimizde ise D orb al 5
tanedir bunların İşte bu isimlerini
vermiş DX y dyz dxz DX k y k x k - y k
ve dz K Bunlar ne demek şöyle bu x y
demek görüyor musun şöyle göstereyim x
düzlemi ve y düzleminin arasında kalıyor
bak X ve Y düzlemleri Bunlar aralarında
kalmış görüyor musun böyle nedir Kelebek
gibi düşünebilirsin bunların basit
gösterimi de var önemlidir basit
gösterimi daha çok çıkar karşına şöyle
yazar mesela şuna y düzlemi Şuna da x
düzlemi yazar şu şekilde gösterir Bak
şöyle düzlemsel olarak gösterirsek böyle
gösterebiliriz ikincisi neymiş D yz yani
y ve z düzlemleri arasında kalıyor bunun
da şekli şöyle olacaktır dostum şurası Z
düzlemi Burası y düzlemi dersen bunların
arasında olacaktır yani şekil 4 yapraklı
yonca sadece x y z yönleri değişmekte
Gördüğün gibi E bu da aynı X ve z
düzlemi arasında şu x k - y k de şu
demektir tam X ve Y koordinatları
üzerinde Bak görüyor musun tam koordin
ordinat üzerinde olduğu için böyle
gösteriliyor ve dz kare O da böyle bir
emzik şeklinde Gördüğün gibi önemlidir
özellikle dz kare üniversite sınavında
da sorulmuştur bu şekil bilmende fayda
var dostum İşte diyor ki D orbitalleri
karmaşık şekillere sahiptir nedir 3üncü
enerji seviyesinden itibaren her enerji
seviyesinde bulunur s her enerji
seviyesinde bulunur p 2'den itibaren
başlıyordu D 3'ten itibaren başlıyordu
f'den bahsedeceğim O da 4'ten itibaren
başlayacak 5 tane
orbitaldeki D orbitali ne dedim 5 tane
dedim yan yana çizdim E bir Orbital en
fazla kaç elektron alabiliyordu 2
elektron alabiliyordu o zaman D'nin
üzerine yazabileceğim en büyük sayı
kaçmış 10m Dostum bunlar önemli şeyler
devam edersek işte ne diyor açısal
olarak koordinatlara bağlıdır yani Ne
oldu X ve z düzlemi X ve Y düzlemi
üzerinde falan yani açısal olarak neye
bağlıymış neymiş bulunma olasılığı
açısal koordinatlara bağlıdır bu ifadeyi
aklında tut sorularda gelecek çünkü
neymiş D orbitalinin elektronun bulunma
olasılığı aç açısal koordinatlara
bağlıdır yani belirli şekilleri vardır
böyle açısal olarak x düzlemi y düzlemi
Z düzleminde bulunabilmektedir bir tek
Kimde yok bu s orbitalinde yok tamam mı
s Çünkü nedir küre şeklindedir gelelim f
orbitaline f orbitalinin şekilleri çok
karışıktır böyle 8 parçalı falandır
burada Görüyorsun bak şöyle yakından
göstereyim sana burada Bak görüyor musun
1 2 3 ne 6ı parçaymış özür 6ı
karışık He Bunu bilmek zorunda mıyız o
zaman değiliz bak şekillerden sorumlu
değilsin Sadece çok karışık şekil
gelirse anla ki F orbitalinden
bahsediyor görüyor musun şekilleri
bunların hiçbirini bilmek zorunda
değilsin tamam mı Yani şunları
ezberlemek zorunda değilsin ha ama s p d
bunlardaki bilmende fayda var sadece FD
kini bilmeyebilir bu isimlerini ne
demiştim 4ün enerji düzeyinden itibaren
her enerji düzeyinde bulunur bunların da
haliyle elektronun bulunma olasılığı
açısal koordinatlara bağlıdır ifadesi ne
olacaktır doğru olacaktır 7 tane Orbital
var O zaman şöyle çizersem Eğer 7 taney
demiş 1 2 3 4 5 6 ve 7 E 7 Orbital varsa
ve bir Orbital en fazla 2 elektron
alabiliyorsa F orbitali toplamda ne
yapacaktır en fazla 14 alabilecektir
yani üzerine yazabileceğimiz en büyük
sayı kaçmış 14' müş dostum Ve tabii ki
bu 7 orbitalin enerjisi de nedir
birbirine eşittir zaten bir Orbital
grubunun hepsinin enerjisi eşit oluyor
Ama şöyle bir şey söylesem mesela 4 f'
nin enerjisiyle 5fn enerjisi eşit mi
Hayır değil ama 4 f' nin içerisindeki şu
7 tane var ya bu 7 tanenin enerjisi
birbirine eşit mi Evet bunlar birbirine
eşit ama 5fn ki tabii ki 4 f'den daha
büyük olacaktır şimdi gel bakalım
sorularımız da ne diyor Diyor ki modern
atom teorisine göre H yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur elektronlar hem
tanecik hem dalga özelliğine sahiptir
Evet zaten Bor atom modelinden ayıran
şey buydu elektronun dalga ve tanecik
ikiliği dediğimiz iki özelliğinin de
olduğunu söyledikleri için zaten bu yeni
Orbital kavramı ve yeni atom modeli
ortaya çıkmıştır bu doğru bir ifade
herhangi bir elektronun aynı anda hızı
ve konumu tespit edilebilir Hayır
Heisenberg Belirsizlik İlkesi vardı
neydi elektronun hızı konumu aynı anda
belirlenemiyorsa
da geçerlidir e hangileri doğrudur
dediği için cevap Ne oldu 1 ve 3 D
seçeneği oldu bu soruya bakalım Diyor ki
aynı atoma ait X ve Y orbitallerinin
sınır yüzey diyagramın yukarıda
verilmiştir yani orbitallerin şekilleri
verilmiştir Bu daha küçük bir s orbitali
bu daha büyük bir s orbitali örnek
veriyorum Mesela bu 1 s ise bu 2s veya
bu 2s ise 3S 4S Neyse Art diğeri daha
büyük ha X ve y'nin İkisi de s Orbital
bir doğru toparlak gördüğün anda s
orbitali ydi diyor ki X'in enerjisi
y'nin kinden düşüktür Evet daha küçük
oldu mu daha küçük enerjiye sahiptir
Doğrudur diyor ki y'nin alabileceği
elektron sayısı x' ininden fazladır ya s
orbitali bir taneydi E bir tane olduğu
için bu da en fazla 2 elektron al
olabilir bu da en fazla 2 elektron
alabilir alabilecekleri maksimum
elektron sayıları eşittir O yüzden
üçüncüsü yanlış oldu Cevap da ne
olacaktır a seçeneği yalnız 3 olacaktır
Burada ne diyor Bakalım P orbitalleri
ile ilgili ikinci enerji seviyesinden
itibaren her enerji seviyesinde bulunur
Evet p orbitali 2'den başlıyordu O
yüzden doğru bir ifade 3p orbitallerinin
Özdeş durumda Enerjileri birbirine
eşittir diyor He bakalım şimdi p
orbitali 3 tane değil miydi Evet
sığdırdık mı sığdırdık biraz aşağı
alayım 3p orbitali E bu p px bu py bu da
pz orbitali bunların enerjisi eşit miydi
eşitti Bunu da söylemiştik Doğrudur
elektronların bulunma olasılıkları
açısal koordinatlara bağlı olup
şekilleri aşağıdaki gibidir diyor Evet
px p y pz doğru bir ifadedir o zaman
hepsi doğru Burada da D seçeneğine
koyulmuş dostum bakalım Bu soruda ne
diyor Yukarıdaki orbitalin bulunduğu
enerji seviyesinde Bak bu 4t yapraklı
yoncayı gördüğümüzde D Orbital didir He
bu en az 3D orbitali Olabilir değil mi D
orbitalleri 3'ten başlıyordu 3D 4D 5D
herhangi birisi ama Sonuçta en az 3
olabilir diyor ki bu enerji seviyesinde
yani 3üncü enerji seviyesinden
bahsedebiliriz şekli küresel olan
Orbital bulunabilir mi yani 3S orbitali
bulunabilir mi Evet bulunabilir eş
enerjili 7 Orbital yani F orbitalinden
bahsediyor atıyorum bu 3D değil de 4D
olamaz mıydı olabilirdi E bundan dolayı
4F orbitali de burada olabilir mi 4
periyotta olsa F orbitali de olabilir
Demek ki bu da bulunabilir diyor ki
elektron bulunma olasılığı açısal
koordinatlara bağlı olmayan Orbital
bağlı olmayan Orbital s orbitali demekti
zaten bulunabileceğini söylemiştik her
neydi her enerji seviyesinde bulunu
biliyordu Doğrudur E o zaman Ne oldu
hepsi doğru oldu Cevap da e seçeneği
burada diyor ki orbitaller ile ilgili
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur
elektronun bulunma ihtimalinin yüksek
olduğu sınır yüzey diyagramları dır Evet
bu ifadeyi kullanmıştık elektronun
bulunma olasılığının yüksek olduğu yere
Orbital diyorduk değil mi farklı
şekilleri olan elektron yoğunluklu
bölgelerdir elektronun yoğun olarak
bulunabileceği şekilleri birbirinden
farklı şeylerde değil mi Bunlar
orbitaller böyleydi şekilleri
birbirinden farklıydı Bu da doğrudur
diyor ki elektronun üç boyutlu
hareketini temsil eder katmanda neydi
iki boyutlu temsil ediyordu orbitalde üç
boyutlu temsil ediyordu söylemiştik Bu
da doğru bir ifadedir o zaman hepsi
doğru cevabımız D seçeneğidir şimdi şu
sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki atomdaki 3üncü
enerji seviyesinden itibaren her enerji
seviyesinde bulunan bir Orbital ile
ilgili hım çok güzel bir Orbital 3üncü
enerji seviyesinden itibaren bulunan
Orbital D Orbital didir bundan
bahsediyor diyor ki aynı enerji
seviyesinde kendisiyle eş enerjili bir
Orbital bulunabilir ya D orbitali 5
taneydi neydi DX y dxz d yz DX k - y k d
z k Bunların hepsi vardı E o zaman Evet
Bunlardan herhangi birini seçtiysen eş
enerjili başka orbitaller var mıymış
varmış Bunu söyleyebiliriz diyor ki
sınır yüzey diyagramı bu şekilde yani dz
karenin şekliydi bu olabilir mi Evet
olabilir En fazla 2 elektron alabilir
diyor E bir Orbital en fazla 2 elektron
alıyor diyor Yani bu ifade de nedir
Doğrudur cevabımız ne olacaktır e
seçeneği olacaktır şimdi şu soruya
bakalım Diyor ki n = 2 olan herhangi bir
Orbital için n = 2 dediği Baş kuantum
sayısı 2 olan neler vardı 2s vardı ya da
2p orbitali vardı küreseldir e s
orbitali olursa evet küreseldir bu
doğrudur yani Olabilir mi Olabilir p
Orbital E bu da olabilir bu da bir
ihtimaldir doğrudur çekirdek etrafında
zıt yönelmiş iki lobdan oluşur diyor iki
lobdan oluşan neydi şöyle çiki loptu
değil mi yani p orbitalinden bahset
ediyoruz bu ifade nedir Doğrudur yani
hepsi Olabilir mi Olabilir cevap da E
seçeneğidir şimdi elektron dizilimi
elektron dağılımı ya da elektronik
konfigürasyon dediğimiz şeyden
bahsedelim İstersen şimdi çok
elektronları açıklayamamıştır ya Bor E
ne oluyor işte modern atom modeli çıktı
burada da bu elektronların orbitallere
yerleşmesinde şimdi çekirdek etrafında
yerleşmeye başladı Tamam birinci katmana
yerleşti sonra ikinci katmana geldik
elektron sayısı artacak daha fazla
elektron yerleşecek ama işte bu
yerleşirken Enerjileri farklı olduğu
için için ne yapacak farklı şekillerde
yönelmeye başlayacak O yüzden 2s 2p gibi
atom orbitalleri ortaya çıkacak bunların
erisinde de enerji farkları artmaya
başlayacak yani 2 S'ye yerleşen
elektronla 2pe yerleşen elektronun
Enerjileri aynı olmayacak dış katmanlara
çıktıkça bu daha da değişmeye başlayacak
elektronlar buralara yerleşecek dostum e
haliyle bu elektronlar yerleştik çe bir
itme meydana getirecek yani elektron
yerleşti ikinci katmana elektron
yerleştiğinde Tamam çekirdek onu çekmeye
çalışıyor ama birinci katmandaki
elektronlar da onu itme çalışıyor e
haliyle ne yapacak kaçmamak için
dışarıya gitmemek için orada durabilmek
için enerjisini arttırması gerekiyor
Bundan dolayı işte O ne oluyor dışarı
doğru çıktıkça enerji artıyor ifadesini
kullanıyoruz ya dış katmanların enerjisi
fazladır diyoruz ya sebebi ne bunun İşte
bu itme kuvvetini yenebilmek dostum ve
şöyle bir şey vardır bir katmanda
olabilecek maksimum elektron sayısını
bulmamız gerekiyor Onu da işte 2n kare
formülüyle buluyoruz dostum Bak burada
gösteriyor 2n K Peki n burada neydi
katman sayısı mesela birinci katman yani
k katmanı klmn Opr diye gidiyordu ya da
işte klmn neyse artık e 1ci katman 2 x
1in karesi Demek ki 1ci katmana en fazla
2 elektron gelebiliyor 2 elektron
gelebiliyor bu s orbitali demekti değil
mi s orbitali 2 elektron oluyor demek ki
birinci katmanda sadece s orbitali var
buradan bunu anlayabiliyoruz sonra 2ci
katmana geldiğimizde 2 x 2in karesi 8
elektron ediyor Ee 2'si s orbitaline
yerleşecek Geriye kalıyor 6 O da p'ye
yerleşecek değil mi 2ci katmanda da s ve
p orbitalleri olacak 3üncü katmana
geldiğimizde 2 x 3'ün karesi 18 elektron
bak 2 s orbitaline 6 p orbitaline geriye
kaldı 10 O da nereye D orbitaline
yerleşecek etti sana 18 e 4 katmana
geldiğimizde 2 x 4'ün karesinden 32 2 s
orbitali 6 p orbitali 10 da D orbitali
kaç etti Burası 18 e geriye kaldı kaç 14
O da F orbitaline yerleşecek değil mi
İşte onu da şöyle buluyoruz bir
katmandaki Orbital sayılarını da şöyle
buluyoruz n kare formülüyle buluyoruz
şimdi 1ci katmanda 1in karesinden 1 S
orbitali var çok güzel 2ci katmana
geldiğimizde 2nin karesinden 4 et e s
orbitali bir taneydi p orbitali 3
taneydi kaç etti toplam 4 Orbit E buraya
geldik 3C katman 3'ün karesi 9 Orbital
olması lazım bu 1 E bu 3 Bu da 5 kaç
etti 9 etti değil mi E 4C katman 4'ün
karesinden 16 e bunda 1 var bunda 3 var
bunda 5 var bunda da 7 var Kaç etti 16
etti Dostum orbitali nasıl gösteriyoruz
ya yuvarlak ya kare şeklinde
gösteriyoruz elektronları da işte bunun
içerisine yerleştiriyoruz tam dolu
dediğimizde elektronları zıt yönde
göstermemiz lazım bir biri yukarı yönlü
isse biri aşağı yönlü ya da şöyle biri
bu yönde isse biri bu yönde gösteriyoruz
buna tam dolu diyoruz yarı doluay İsa
elektron ne olacaktır ya böyle ya böyle
ya da işte böyle ya da böyle ya da şöyle
ya da şöyle yerleşecek Dostum şimdi çok
elektronlarda bu elektronları
orbitallere Yazacağım da bunun kuralı
var enerjiye göre yazılmakta Peki bu
enerji nasıl değişiyor onu sana İşte o n
ve L değerleri var ya ona göre
anlatacağım şimdi bak Birinci katmanda
en fazla 1 S vardı ikinci katmanda 2 S
varı Bir de 2p vardı 3 katmanda 3S
olabiliyordu 3p olabiliyordu 3D
olabiliyordu 4 katman 4S 4p 4D 4F
olabiliyordu 5 katmanda 5S 5p 5D 5f 6
katman 6s 6p 6D 6f yazıyorum 7 katman 7s
yazdım yeterli şimdi bir orbitalin
enerjisi n + l değeriyle bulunur n + l
değeriyle bu büyükse enerjisi büyüktür
ha Peki n + l'si eşit olanlarda ne
yapacağız n değeri büyük olan şöyle eşit
değil büyük olanın enerjisi daha
büyüktür şimdi bak s orbitalinin şöyle s
p d f vardı L değerleri s'nin 0'dı P'nin
1'di D'nin 2'ydi fninternbasvuru
n sayısı büyük olan E bu gördüğün gibi
Demek ki 3 s'nin enerjisi daha büyükmüş
şuraya geldik 3 + 1 değil mi 4 bu 3 + 2
kaç etti 5 şöyle yazamadık He şu 4 + 0
Ne oldu 4 4 + 1 5 Bu da ev gibi oldu lan
4 + 2 kaç etti 6 4 + 3 kaç etti 7 E bu 5
+ 0 değil mi 5 bu 5 + 1 kaç etti 6
Burası 5 + 2'den 7 5 + 3'ten 8 Ya
bunları kullanmayacağım da bir kıyaslama
yapmak için gösteriyorum bu 6 6 0'dan 6
+ 0'dan söyleyemedim bu 6 + 1'den 7 E bu
6 + 2 8 Buna gerek yok Bu da 7 + 0'dan 7
şimdi dedik ya elektronlar enerjiye göre
yerleşiyor şöyle bir şey vardır albağ
kuralından bahsedeceğim birazdan albağ
kuralı enerjisi düşükten başlayarak
elektronları yerleştirir o zaman Buraya
bakarsak şöyle enerjisi en düşük olan 1s
oldu değil mi Sonra Sırada ne var Bak bu
1 olduğu için sonra 2 s var o da gitti
sonra bak 3 olan ik tane var E ne
yapacağız enerjisi Düşük olana önce
yerleşi oldu 2p Sonra 3S geldi sonra bak
Dikkat et renk değiştiriyorum şuradan 4
olan şu var Ve şu var Gördün mü o zaman
3p Sonra da 4S Aha bak bak çok önemli
bir şey var burada görüyor musun Hemen
bir daha renk değiştiriyorum 5 olan
hangisi var bu var başka şu var Başka
var mı Evet bu da var düşükten
başlıyordu 3D sonra 4p sonra da 5 sonra
6lar başlıyor bak 6 olanlar hangisi
şurada var başka şurada var şurada var
onları yazalım Ne oldu 4E 5p 6s He bir
de ne var 7'ler var bak 7 olanlar burada
burada ve şurada onu da siyahla
Göstereceğim ne olacak o zaman 4F 5D 6p
ve 7s şeklinde olacak işte sıralama bu
şekilde ortaya çıkmakta bunun bir kuralı
var basit bir kuralı var s' den 2 tane p
s'en 2 tane DP s'en 2 tane fdp s'en bir
tane yazarak aynı sıralamaya
ulaşabilirsin nasıl hemen yazıyorum Bak
şimdi s' den iki tane yazdım s s ik tane
PS yazdım PS PS sonra 2 tane dps d p s d
p s sonra bir tane f d p s yazdım şimdi
ne demiştik S'ler birden başlıyordu 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 p' 2'den başlıyordu 2 3 sonra
4 5 6 sonra d'ler 3'ten başlıyordu 3 4 5
ve f' 4'ten başlıyordu bak aynı
sıralamaya ulaştık dostum İşte geldim
bak nereye aufbau ilkesine kurallarımız
şu aufbau kuralında şöyle söyler temel
haldeki atomlarda elektronlar en düşük
enerjiye sahip orbitalden başlayarak
sırasıyla yüksek enerjiye doğru
dolmaktadır Burada da gösteriyor işte 1
S 2 S bak s'leri p' hepsini yazmış sonra
bak ne yapmış gelmiş 1 S 2 s 2p 3S sonra
3p 4S gelmiş 3D 4p 5S bu şekilde gidiyor
dostum benim say say para say para say
daha para say daha para say Fatma daha
para say şeklindeki kodlamam daha da
güzel olacaktır hemen aşağıya da
göstereyim istersen Bak burada da
yazmışız neydi s' den 2 tane psen 2 tane
DP s'en 2 tane fdp s'en bir tane
yazarsan aynı sıralama çıkıyor bak say
say para say para say daha para say daha
para say Fatma daha para say diye
gidiyor işte en düşük
enerjilenme gerekiyor öyle söyleyeyim
sana en fazla genel olarak çıkan şudur
1s 2s 2p 3S 3p 4S 3D 4p 5S genellikle
buraya kadar çıkıyor Hadi bir de
devamına 4D yi ekleyelim Ama genellikle
buraya kadar çıkıyor ikinci kuralımız da
şunu söyler Hun kuralı eş enerjili
orbitalleri mesela p orbitali var ya 3
tane orbitalden oluşuyordu İşte bu eş
enerjili orbitallere elektronlar
yerleşirken önce boş orbitale yerleşiyor
boşlar dolduktan sonra yanlarına
diğerleri yerleşiyor Ben bunu şuna
benzetiyorum dostum otobüse metrobüs
diyelim ya Metrobüs daha iyi bir örnek
metrobüse bindiğinde Ne oluyor dostum
metrobüste o kapı açılacak diyelim ilk
duraktı diyelim oturabileceğin yani çok
zor da diyelim hadi metrobüse
oturabildiği düşünelim şanslı
insanlardan birisin Kapılar Bir açılıyor
hurra millet bir dalıyor ne oluyor
dikkat et hepsinin ikili koltuk olduğunu
düşünürsek önce cam kenarları tık tık
tık tık tık tık hepsi doluyor cam
kenarları dolduktan sonra yanlarına tık
tık tık tık diğerleri gelmeye başlıyor
işte aynı onun gibi dostum ne oluyor
biliyor musun Şöyle mesela p
orbitalinden bahsedelim şöyle ü tane
Orbital var önce bir tanesi geldi Buraya
yerleşti diğeri buraya yerleşmek zorunda
değil sonuçta aynı enerjiye sahip buraya
da yerleşebilir sıkıntı yok ama üçüncü
kişi yani 3üncü elektron nereye
yerleşmek zorunda buraya gelmek zorunda
dördüncü elektron hangisine yerleşir ya
istediğini tercih eder isterse bundan
başlar Çünkü eş enerjili sonraki gelecek
diyelim buraya yerleşti He sonuncu
mecburen buraya yerleşmek zorunda Peki
diyelim p4 var p4u şöyle yazdım diyelim
şu şekilde şöyle olur mu Olur p4 Mesela
şöyle olur mu tık tık tık tık olur mu bu
da olur Mesela p4 şöyle olur mu olmaz
Ben bunu şuna benzetiyorum diyelim
fatura yatıracaksın fatura yatırırken L
ekrana sığdıramam şım iyi mi Heh biraz
küçülte şöyle biraz biraz şöyle içeri
alayım da siz de görmüş olun He şöyle
söylüyordum fatura yatıracaksın diyelim
3 tane ane vezne var bu ü tane vezneye
gittin üçü de boş ne yaparsın istediğin
vezneye seçersin değil mi diyelim Sen
sıraya girdin peşine birisi daha geldi
gelen kişi senin arkanda mı bekler Gider
yan taraftaki
boşlu gider değil mi üçüncü kişi ne
yapar gider diğer boşa değil mi E gidip
de senin arkanda bekler mi salak değil
herhalde beklemez e Düşünsene ü tane
vezne var dör kişi gelmiş ikişer ikişer
bekliyorsunuz ya vezne kapalıysa ancak
girmemiş olursunuz veya başka bir işle
uğraşıyordu ama hani şey şartlar Türkiye
şartlarından bahsetmiyorum ben hani
genel olarak ifade ediyorum yani ne olur
orada önce birer tane dolar 4C kişi de
istediğini tercih eder değil mi dostum
işte Bak burada azot 7'den bahsetmiş
neydi 1s Tamam 2s 2p böyle gidiyor Hatta
yazayım Bak 1s 2s 2p bu elektronlar
nasıl yerleşiyor şöyle göstereyim 7
değil mi nötral de 7 protonu varsa 7 de
elektronu var s en fazla kaç
alabiliyordu 2 alabiliyordu yazdık
geriye kaç kaldı 5 bu s en fazla 2
alabiliyordu bunu da yazdık geriye ne
kaldı 3 o zaman 3 de buna kaldı ha bu
3'e elektronlar nasıl yerleşecek şöyle
gelip de önce birer tane böyle
yerleşecek Hocam niye yukarı yönlü
çizdin şöyle olmaz mı biri yukarı biri
aşağı böyle olmaz önce aynı yönde sonra
zıt yönde tamam mı dostum İşte böyle
yerleşir mi yerleşemez önce birer tane
de olacak sonra he böyle yerleşebilir mi
yerleşemez peki bu Evet olur doğrusu bu
zaten bu bu da olur sonuçta aynı yönde
yerleşmesi gerekiyor tamam mı dostum
hauli dışlama ilkesi var Bu da aslında
gerçekte şunu söyler bir atomdaki iki
elektronun kuantum sayılarının hepsi
aynı olamaz en az birisi farklı olmak
zorunda ki bu da zaten Spin kuantum
sayısı yani elektronun yönü demektir
dostum burada ne oluyor Bir orbitalde
bulunan iki elektron aynı spinli olamaz
aynı yönde olamaz demek istiyor Peki
Spin dediğimiz şey ne elektronun dönüş
yönü biri saat yönünde döner Diğeri de
saat yönünün zıttına döner bir
orbitaldeki elektron O yüzden zaten
birini yukarı birini aşağı çiziyoruz
yukarı çizdiğimiz saat yönü aşağı
çizdiğimiz saat yönünün tersi olarak if
ifade edilmektedir bunu şöyle söyleyeyim
sana dostum Bak iki tane elektron tamam
mı birisi işte bu yönde dönüyor Diğeri
ise bu yönde dönüyor Yani iki elektron
bu şekilde zıt yönlerde dönebilmektedir
dostum Tamam bunu yapabilen varsa görmek
isterim açıkçası He o zaman helyumun
mesela iki tane elektronu var değil mi
bu iki elektronu nasıl
yerleştirirseniz
yapamazsın dostum tamam mı Çünkü bir
orbitale iki elektron zıt yönde
yerleşmek zorunda tamam mı dostum Mesela
bak diyor ki Yukarıdaki elektronların
orbitallere yerleşimlerinden hangileri
hund kuralına uymaz diyor Hunt kuralı He
ne oluyordu Hunt kuralında önce birer
tane dolacak sonra diğerleri dolmaya
başlayacak bu olur mu olabilir sıkıntı
yok p4 Böyle olur mu Olmaz önce birer
tane sonra diğeri değil mi D2 diyor olur
sonuçta aynı enerjiye sahip bununla buna
yerleşmiş ya isterse bununla Buna da
yerleşebilir de sıkıntı yok yani bu da
olabilir uymaz sorduğu için cevap Ne
oldu B seçeneği y yız 2 oldu burada Ne
diyor bakalım Yukarıdaki ifadelerden
hangileri doğrudur Alba kuralına göre
elektronlar yüksek enerjili orbitalden
başlayarak Hayır afba ne diyordu düşük
enerjilenme yani zıt yönde olmak zorunda
hund kuralına göre eş enerjili
orbitallere elektronlar Önce tek tek
yerleşir sonra diğer yönde yerleşir
doğru bir ifade cevap ne olacaktır 2 ve
3 doğruları sorduğu için D seçeneği
buraya bakalım Diyor ki elektron Orbital
şeması yukarıda verilen x element atomu
ile ilgili ifadelerinden hangileri
doğrudur diye soruyor şimdi Buraya
bakarsak ilki neydi s orbitali ydi 1s Bu
ne 2s Buraya bakarsak 3 tane Orbital var
bu nedir 2p orbitali e Sırada ne var 3S
orbitali var E bir dakika şimdi birini
doldurmadan diğerine nasıl geçiyorsun
sen arkadaş burada toplamda bak sayarsak
2 4 6 8 10 tane elektron var bu x'i
yazıyorum bak 10 elektronu şöyle
yazıyorum 1s 2s 2p 3S diye kalsın da
kullanacak mıyım kullanmayacak mıyım
öğreneceğim şimdi s en fazla 2
alabiliyordu yazdık şöyle zoomlayan
Hatta E diğer s en fazla 2 alabiliyordu
kaç etti 4 e 10 vardı geriye ne kaldı 6
kaldı E bunu dolduracak sonra diğerine
geçecek yani Buraya elektron gelmemesi
lazımdı dizilim böyle olması gerekiyordu
He bakalım şimdi diyor ki albağ kuralına
Uygundur diyor Hayır alt enerji
seviyesini doldurmadan üst enerji
seviyesine geçmiş o yüzden bu yanlıştır
elektron içeren orbitalleri tam doludur
e verdikleri bu hali Evet hepsi tam dolu
Gördüğün gibi bir yukarı bir aşağı
şekilde Doğrudur çekirdek yükü 10'dur
diyor e toplam 10 elektronu varsa temel
halde E ne olacaktır 10 da protonu
olacaktır yani proton sayısı çekirdek
yükü 10 demektir Doğrudur cevap 1 ve 3
olmalı C seçeneği şim şu soruya bakalım
zaten kuralı verdiğim için kafam rahat
neydi s p d f orbitali ydi L değerlerini
vermiştim 0 1 2 3 şimdi Bu ne 2 + 1
değil mi 2 + 1'den bunun enerjisi 3
birim Bu da 3 + 0'dan bunun enerjisi de
3 birim e Bunlar eşit olduğunda n sayısı
büyük olanın enerjisi daha büyük oluu
yani sıralama böyle olmalı Buraya
bakarsak 4 + 3'ten 7 e burası 5 + 0'dan
kaç etti 5 Evet bu doğrudur enerjisi
büyük olan 4F imiş şuraya geldiğimizde
ise 3 + 2'den 5 4 + 0dan 4 evet bu daha
büyüktür Bu da doğrudur cevap ne
olacaktır D seçeneği olacaktır işte sana
o yüzden öğrettim bu kuralı bir daha
ezberleme o sıralamada hangisi şöyleydi
hangisi böyleydi diye ezberleme diye
sana bunu öğrettim yani L değerlerini ve
n değerlerini bindiğinde n değerleri
işte O baştaki sayılar 3 4 5 diye
gidiyor L değerleri ise s orbitali için
0 p orbitali için 1 D orbitali için 2 ve
F orbitali için 3 değeridir bu şekilde
kafanda tutarsan bu soruları yanlış
yapmazsın dostum bu sorumuza Bakalım 3
S1 ve 4 S1 orbitalleri ile ilgili
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur s
orbitalinin şekli böyle yuvarlak değil
miydi yani şekilleri aynıdır doğru 4
s'nin enerjisi 3 c'den büyüktür Evet
S'ler olduğunda 4 olduğunda Tabii ki
enerjisi daha büyük olacaktır Doğrudur 4
s'nin çekirdeğe uzaklığı 3 s'nin kinden
büyüktür şimdi 3S buysa 4S budur e
haliyle 4S çekirdeğe daha uzaktır doğru
bir ifadedir cevap 1 2 3 burada a
seçeneğinde dostum burada diyor ki
toplam 32 elektron alabilen enerji
seviyesi ile ilgili Yukarıdaki
ifadelerden hangis hangileri doğrudur
Hım toplam 32 elektron alabilen 2n kare
formülüne göre buranın 32 olması demek n
k = 16 n = 4 demektir 4 katmandan
bahsediyor 4 enerji seviyesi olabilir mi
olabilir Bunu söyleyebiliriz diyor ki s
p d f orbitallerin içerir n = 4'te s
vardı p vardı D vardı F vardı o yüzden
Doğrudur diyor ki içerdiği tüm
elektronların temel enerji seviyesi
aynıdır e haliyle hepsi aynı aynı
katmanda temel enerji seviyesi olarak
yani 4 katmanda doğru bir ifadedir
Enerjileri aynıdır demiyor bak temel
enerji seviyeleri yani katman sayıları
aynıdır demek istiyor o yüzden cevap 1 2
3 e seçeneği olacak Dostum şimdi burada
Ne diyor bakalım bir enerji sıralaması
vermiş kesinlikle yanlıştır soruyor Hım
şimdi 5p yani 5 + 1 bunun enerjisi 6 bu
neymiş en büyükmüş Bu ne 3D 3D olduğuna
göre 3 + 2'den Aha bu da ne bu 5 He
şeymiş 6 zannettim He 5'mi o zaman
Şuradaki 6 da olabilir 5 de olabilir bak
6 da olabilir 5 de olabilir buraya
gelecekleri yazıyorum Burası 5p ise
şuraya gelebilecekler 5S olabilir başka
toplamları 6 olan bir şey düşünelim
şöyle ne olabilir 4D olabilir mi 4D
olabilir Sonuçta 5p den daha düşük
enerjiye sahip toplamı 6 ama baştaki
sayı küçük olduğu için Başka ne olabilir
Düşünüyorum Düşünüyorum Burası 6s olamaz
çünkü 6 + 0 xi de 6 ama baştaki sayı
büyük olduğu için bunu yazamayız 6 s
olamayacaktır başka başka düşünelim
Başka ne olabilir buranın toplamı 6
olacak başka bir örnek var mıdır 4F
olmaz o 7 olmadı başka başka 5'ler
düşünelim mesela 5S yazılabilir mi
yazılabilir olur Başka ne olabilir 4p
Olabilir mi E bu da olabilir 4 + 1'den
dolayı bu da olabilir başka düşünüyorum
düşünüyorum Başka Şu an aklıma gel 5S
zaten iki kere yazmışım Gördüğün gibi
şöyle onu kaldıralım şimdi o zaman
bakalım Diyor ki N = 5 olabilir mi
olabilir diyor ki x F orbitali olabilir
diyor ya bak F orbitali olsa bak F
orbitali olsa burası 3F olmaz En az 4
olmak zorunda e 4 + 3'ten dolayı 7 olur
yani buranın F orbitali olma ihtimali 0
hiç yok diyor ki A = 2 olabilir diyor
Hım bakalım şimdi yani üzerindeki
elektron sayısı örnek veriyorum işte 5
S2 Olamaz mı olabilir bunda sıkıntı yok
diyor ki A = 10 10 olabilir diyor bak 4D
orbitali olsa burası 10 Olamaz mı
olabilir bunda da sıkıntı yok n = 4 yani
4D 4p Bunlar olabileceği için n = 4 de
olabilir ama kesinlikle olmayacak şey
buradaki orbitalin F orbitali olmasıdır
cevap o yüzden B seçeneğidir Şimdi
burada Ne diyor bakalım NS üzeri a ile
np üzeri B orbitalleri için
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur diyor A
= B olabilir ya sonuçta şöyle NS 2 np2
Olamaz mı olabilir Sonuçta p 6'ya kadar
alabiliyor 6'nın altındaki her sayıyı
alabilir O yüzden bu olabilir n eş 1
olamaz Doğru söylüyor Çünkü 1 S orbitali
vardır ama 1 p orbitali yoktur yani
şunun 1 olma ihtimali yok p 2'den
başlıyordu O yüzden bu da doğru bir
ifadedir burada ne demiş np üzeri B'nin
enerjisi NS üzeri A'nın enerjisinden
yüksektir örnek veriyorum 4p üzeri 6 Bu
da 4S üzeri 2 ya Bun buların önemi yok 4
+ 1'den 5 4 + 0'dan 4 ya da şöyle düşün
n + 1 Burası Aslında bu da n + 0 e
haliyle 4 P'nin enerjisi Daha doğrusu
şöyle söyleyeyim n P'nin enerjisi daha
yüksektir Doğrudur cevap Ne oldu 1 2 3
burada a seçeneğine koyulmuş Dostum Evet
Bence ara verme vakti geldi Bir sonraki
derste bu elektron dizilimlerini devam
edeceğim daha detaylı örnekler vereceğim
sen bu ders yaptıklarımızı bir sindir
Nelerden bahsettik bak çok önemli
şeylerden bahsettik Orbital şekilleri
önemli D'ye kadar tabii ki başka neyden
bahsettik Bu enerji sıralaması vardı 1 S
2 S falan var ya işte o sıralama ona bir
bak Mümkünse şeye kadar bu 5 p'ye kadar
kısma baksan iyi olur ezberlemeye
çalışsan iyi olur diye düşünüyorum Hun
kuralı auf B kuralı pauli dışlama ilkesi
Bunların ne olduğuna bir daha bak çok
önemlidir Çünkü buradan çok patates
ederler adamı O yüzden oraya dikkat
etmeni istiyorum Bir de tabii ki Ne
yapıyorsun Soru çözüyorsun OGM materyal
kullanabilirsin Milli Eğitim
Bakanlığı'nın kitapları size verdiği
kitapların sorularını çözebilirsin
bunlardan faydalanmanın istiyorum Ayrıca
IQ 9 sınıf kimya soru bankası da
alabilirsin orada da çok kıyak sorular
var çok güzel sorular var bazılarını
çözeceğim ben onlara da bakabilirsin
dostum o zaman ara verme vakti iki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça kal